Prof: Okay,
so let's pickup where we left
off on Monday,
and we were starting to talk in
more detail about MacIntyre's
argument.
And one of the things I want to
zero in centrally on today is
his account of human psychology,
or what used to be called human
nature.
And that differs importantly
from every account of human
psychology we've looked at thus
far for a number of reasons,
and I'm going to spell them out
in a little bit more detail than
we talked about on Monday.
Basically it is an Aristotelian
conception of the structure of
human psychology,
and that has a number of
features to it.
One is that I mentioned to you,
that we think of human beings
as teleological creatures.
We are purposive creatures.
We always want to know what the
point of an activity is.
Now if you go back to
Aristotle, Aristotle held the
view that while we are purposive
creatures we only reason about
the means to achieve our goals,
not the goals themselves.
For Aristotle,
Aristotle's conception of
virtue,
the virtues,
the virtues were given for all
time,
and he had his list of the
virtues which you can find if
you go back and read the
Nicomachean
Ethics.
They're things like,
courage, honesty,
and various others,
perhaps debatable,
perhaps not.
But in any event in Aristotle's
scheme of things,
what we reason about is the
means to achieve the virtues,
not the virtues themselves.
And I'm going to come back to
that because one of the respects
in which MacIntyre differs from
Aristotle is that he wants to
say the virtues--
he wants to at least go this
far with the Enlightenment
thinkers,
he wants to say that what
counts as a virtue is,
to some extent, up for debate.
Just to what extent and how we
debate it are things that I'll
come back to.
But the more important point is
that this as an account of the
structure of human psychology we
need to know what the point is.
We have goals.
We have purposes.
When those purposes are met
we're happy and fulfilled.
When they're not met we're
frustrated and unsatisfied and
discontented.
Just to give you a somewhat
different perspective on this
approach to thinking about human
psychology I would say that the
other influential Aristotelian
of our time,
besides Alasdair MacIntyre,
is the Nobel Prize winning
economist Amartya Sen who
develops the idea of human
potentiality as the core notion.
That we're people who have
potential,
and unless we realize our
potential we're going to be in
some basic sense incomplete,
not fulfilled not happy human
beings.
And so in Sen's account of
justice,
which I wish we had time to
talk about in this course but we
don't,
it's analogous that he's an
economist,
not a philosopher,
so he brings the considerations
of an economist to this
question.
But it's the same question of
human beings who have a certain
kind of potential that has to be
realized in order for them to be
fulfilled in their teleological
capacity,
that has to occur.
And so with MacIntyre,
too, it's this idea of the
structure of human psychology
being goal-directed,
and we'll get into the content
later.
But so that's the first thing,
and then the second was that
our behavior is,
in a very fundamental way,
other-directed.
So just, again,
by way of comparison think back
to the assumptions about
other-directedness in previous
thinkers who we have considered
in this course.
When we focused on the
utilitarian tradition we saw
people as essentially
self-referential.
Remember Ronald Reagan's famous
question in 1984,
"Are you better off than
you were four years ago?"
was a self-referential question.
"Are you better off than
you were four years ago?"
All you have to look at is how
you were faring four years ago
and how you're faring now,
and ask yourself that question.
Other people don't enter into
it at all.
Then when we considered Marxism
we came to think about
other-directed conceptions of
human psychology in that Marx
made our welfare critically
reliant on what others get.
And so he said that your
perception of whether you're
exploited turns upon what your
employer gets.
Remember we talked about this
in some depth and concluded that
Marx was half-right in that
people are often other-directed
in that their sense of whether
what they get is legitimate is
dependent on what others get,
but what he was wrong about was
that people tend to compare
themselves to people who are
similarly situated in the
socioeconomic order.
So autoworkers compare
themselves maybe to steel
workers, but not to auto
executives, and they don't make
those kinds of global
comparisons.
Nonetheless there is something
to this idea that people's
conception of their welfare is
connected to what others get,
and so relative inequalities
matter simply from the
perspective of your feeling of
how well-off you are.
And you can tell yourself any
number of stories to make this
point.
The telling one,
quite often,
I think is you give a child a
glass of orange juice that's
half full and he's very happy,
and then you give his sister
one that's completely full and
he immediately becomes unhappy
because what matters to him is
the relative difference and not
what he has in his glass.
So that's a notion of
other-directed.
And of course you can take this
notion of other-directed
further,
still, by linking your utility
not just to what other people
get,
but to actually what other
people experience.
And this is the concept of
interdependent utility,
as it gets referred to in the
literature.
And the examples here are
things like a parent taking
pleasure in their child's
success and feeling pain at
their child's lack of success.
One of the famous one-liners
that parents will resonate with
is, "You can only be as
happy as your least happy
child."
So if your kids are unhappy
then you are miserable.
That's the notion of
interdependent utility.
Your happiness is conditioned
on what others get,
but not just in making us a
relative judgment with the
orange juice kind of a case,
but your happiness becomes
dependent on what people
actually themselves experience,
hence interdependent utility.
The example of the child's
happiness making the parent--
or the child's success making
the parent happy is an
interdependent positive utility,
but of course there are
interdependent negative
utilities as well as when a
sadist's or a rapist's utility
goes up as a byproduct of their
victim's utility going down.
Again, that interdependent
negative utility,
and it's the mirror image of
interdependent positive utility.
The Aristotelian conception
that MacIntyre embraces takes
interdependent utilities a step
further even than that,
though, in that it's not just
that your happiness,
or satisfaction,
or fulfillment is conditioned
upon the experience of others,
but it's the experience of
others as it relates to you.
It's the others' experience of
you, if you like.
And so a good example of this
actually comes from Hegel's
Phenomenology where he
talks about this dialectic
between the master and the slave
as being inherently unstable.
But it's not just unstable
because the slave is going to
find it unsatisfactory.
It's unstable because the
master will find it
unsatisfactory.
Hegel says, in The
Phenomenology,
that what we want most
fundamentally is recognition
from others,
but it can't be recognition
from others that we don't
respect.
So recognition of a slave
saying, "Yes,
master.
No, master,"
is not going to be satisfactory
or fulfilling to you.
What you want is recognition
from an equal or perhaps a
superior, but you want
recognition from somebody whose
recognition can be valuable to
you.
It's a source of feeling valued
by somebody you value.
So it takes this idea,
as I said, of interdependent
utility even a step further
because it now goes to the
reciprocal relationship between
you and the other person,
and that is the idea of
practices.
It's this sort of neo-Hegelian
idea in this particular sense
that informs MacIntyre's notion
of a practice.
When I gave you the example on
Monday I said,
"If I build sheds and
write books,
it's not enough for me to have
the carpenters say,
'Oh, you wrote a good book,'
and the academics say,
'That's a nice shed.'
I want the carpenter to say
that's a good shed,
and the people who know about
writing books to say,
'This is a good book.'"
That's the notion of he's a
pitchers' pitcher.
You want recognition from
people for whom you have esteem
at the relevant activity.
So this is a different,
again, view of the structure of
human psychology.
All of these different theories
are predicated on some account
of the structure of human
psychology.
And indeed, I think that one
thing you should be seeing as we
move through and examine these
different arguments is that
every political theory has an
account of human psychology,
and an account of how the world
operates causally.
And you need to sometimes dig
to get them out,
but one of the ways in which
you should evaluate them is you
should ask yourself,
"What is the theory of
human psychology driving this?
Does it make sense?
Is it true to my own experience
or not, and if not why
not?"
That's one question,
and then the second is,
"What are the assumptions
about how the world works
causally?"
and I'll come back to those in
relation to MacIntyre again.
But you could go through all
the thinkers we've considered
and find assumptions and
arguments about those two
things,
and they provide a very good
comparative reference point for
thinking about how they stack up
against one another as we've
just seen as went from the
utilitarian,
to the Marxian,
to the different variance of
other-referential assumptions
about human psychology.
So this is the MacIntyre
approach that what we really
want out of life is esteem from
people who we esteem,
and that operates through these
practices as he describes them.
And this is just a summary
statement of what I've already
told you, where he says,
virtues as he describes them
are embedded in practices.
"It belongs to the concept
of a practice as I have outlined
it--
and as we're all familiar with
it in our actual lives,
whether we are painters or
physicists or quarterbacks or
indeed just lovers of good
painting,
or first rate experiments or a
well-thrown pass--
that its goods can only be
achieved by subordinating
ourselves within the practice in
our relationships to other
practitioners.
We have to learn to recognize
what is due to whom;
we have to be prepared to take
whatever self-endangering risks
are demanded along the way;
and we have to listen carefully
to what we are told about our
own inadequacies and to reply
with the same carefulness for
the facts."
So this is the notion that I
translated into the proposition
that when you walk into your
first Yale College course,
you don't look around and say
to the people next to you,
"How should we run this
course?
What should we agree too?"
On the contrary what you do is
say, "What is the practice?
What are the norms?
What are the rules?
How do I do well here?
What's expected of me?
How will know if I'm doing
well?"
It might occur to you much
later on to say,
"That wasn't a very
well-run course.
It could have been run better
if this, that and the
other."
So you can criticize,
and I'll come back to that
point later,
but you can only criticize on
the basis of first having
internalized the norms governing
the practice.
You don't criticize somebody's
pitching style in major league
baseball until you've learned a
lot about pitching.
Or maybe you do.
You sit there and throw your
beer can at the screen,
"Err, he's terrible,"
but it's not the form of
criticism he is going to care
about,
and that's the point,
and it's not likely to be the
criticism that makes any
difference.
So rather than the voluntary
agent being at the center of
things,
which is the workmanship story,
this anti-Enlightenment story
subordinates the individual to
the practice,
to the group,
to the inherited system of
norms and values.
And if you want a contemporary
reference point just,
again, to sharpen the
comparison here,
compare the Cartesian idea
which puts the willing agent at
the center of the universe with
the Ubuntu,
which is a kind of African
religion which does the
contrarian thing.
Instead of, "I think
therefore I am,"
it's "I am because we are,
and since we are,
therefore I am."
So it's this idea of
subordinating yourself to an
inherited system of norms and
practices in which you find
yourself,
not which you created or
hypothetically might have
created,
but rather in which you find
yourself.
So this is a fundamental
difference.
It doesn't get more fundamental
than this,
I think, because as you've seen
in every variant of
Enlightenment thinking,
it's the willing creative agent
that is at the ultimate bottom
of the heap,
and here it's not.
It's the subordinated
individual, and the community,
or the practice,
or the tradition to which the
person is subordinated that is
at the very bottom of the heap.
So this is really a fundamental
difference.
So, features of Aristotelian,
or we might call it
neo-Aristotelian psychology;
one is we're teleological in
the sense of being purposive.
We have potential to realize
and realizing that potential is
essential to our happiness.
It's not just getting more of
what gives you utility.
There's some developmental
dimension to this.
Second, the individual is
subordinated to a practice,
and that translates into this
idea of the community becoming
before the individual in
politics.
But third, and in some ways for
MacIntyre's story most important
of all, is that on the
Aristotelian scheme human nature
is malleable.
It's plastic.
It can be shaped in different
ways.
And what is so deeply misguided
about the Enlightenment project
from MacIntyre's point of view
is that it does not take account
of this fact.
It does not take account of the
fact that human beings are
malleable creatures.
Human psychology is shaped by
circumstances.
And so when Rousseau says at
the start of The Social
Contract,
"I'm going to reason about
politics taking men as they are
and laws as they might be,"
that underscores the fact that
Rousseau is missing the
developmental features of human
psychology and reasoning about
politics.
And it's in missing that that
the Enlightenment project went
off the rails.
So let's talk about Aristotle's
scheme.
Let me just read this to you
and then I will explain it if
you haven't understood it.
He says in his description,
"We thus have a threefold
scheme in which human-nature-as-
it-happens-to-be (human nature
in its untutored [or raw]
state) is initially discrepant
and discordant with the precepts
of ethics and needs to be
transformed by the instruction
of practical reason and
experience into human-nature-as-
it-could-be-if-i
t-realized-its-telos.
Each of the three elements of
the scheme--
the conception of untutored
human nature,
the conception of the precepts
of rational ethics,
and the conception of
human-nature-as-
it-could-be-if-i
t-realized-its-telos--
requires reference to the other
two if its status and function
are to be intelligible."
So his point here is,
if you go back and read
Aristotle, he had a view of raw,
or untutored,
or brute human nature,
how we are when we are born.
Then he had an account of human
beings as they could be if they
realized their telos,
their purposes,
and then he had an account of
the rules that get you from the
one to the other.
The rules, the norms that get
you from the one to the other,
and those are the rules of
ethics.
So what are the rules of ethics?
The rules of ethics are those
things that get you from
untutored or raw human nature to
the kinds of beings who realize
their telos or purposes.
And that's why,
if you look at ancient
philosophers like Aristotle or
Plato,
the two central features of
their political theories that
are completely absent when you
read,
say John Rawls,
are a theory of family life and
a theory of education.
It would have been bizarre
beyond imagining for Aristotle
or Plato to think you could have
a theory of politics that didn't
put a huge amount of attention
to those two things.
Think of how many people in
this room have read Plato's
Republic,
at least a good number of you.
That's a book about politics.
Think how much of that is about
how to rear children and the
system of education that has to
prevail,
an enormous amount of it,
probably half the book.
There's nothing of that in
Rawls's Theory of
Justice, or Mill's account
in On Liberty.
So it's a big difference,
and the reason is--and the same
is true of Aristotle's ethics
and his other writings about
politics.
Lots of attention to education,
to the family,
to these things that involve
shaping this malleable plastic
human nature so that we have a
good outcome rather than a bad
outcome.
And so what bugs MacIntyre is,
he's saying,
"We want to derive the
rules of ethics from human
nature as it is,
as we find it.
But that's never going to work
because the rules of ethics are
designed to improve behavior,
not to simply aggregate
behavior.
And so anything we design
that's just derived from people
as they happen to be is going to
seem unsatisfying to us,
unsatisfactory to us.
So to go back to the examples,
we discussed affirmative
action,
the ones he mentions at the
beginning of the book,
abortion, affirmative action
and so on.
Yes, we're going to see people
have different values and
therefore different views about
those questions,
but they're not going to
ultimately be satisfied with
just recognizing their
differences,
because they have inherited a
whole language of talking about
ethics that presumes these
things can be resolved.
There is more to ethical
disagreement than just accepting
the differences among us.
And that, at the end of the
day, is why the Enlightenment
project was a fool's errand.
This is just MacIntyre's more
eloquent and lucid statement of
what I've been saying to you for
the last five minutes,
that I'm capable of.
He says, "Since the moral
injunctions were originally at
home in a scheme in which their
purpose was to correct,
improve and educate that human
nature,
they are clearly not going to
be such as could be deduced from
true statements about human
nature."
Just think of Bentham.
He says, "We are driven by
pleasure-seeking and
pain-avoiding.
I'm going to derive a whole
system from that."
MacIntyre is saying,
"That's crazy because
these moral injunctions were
designed to be at odds with
human nature."
"The injunctions of
morality, thus understood,
are likely to be ones that
human nature...has strong
tendencies to disobey.
Hence the eighteenth-century
moral philosophers engaged in
what was an inevitably
unsuccessful project;
for they did indeed attempt to
find a rational basis for their
moral beliefs in a particular
understanding of human nature,
while inheriting a set of moral
injunctions on the one hand and
a conception of human nature on
the other,
which had been expressly
designed to be discrepant with
each other."
"They inherited incoherent
fragments of a once coherent
scheme of thought and action
and,
since they did not recognize
their own peculiar historical
and cultural situation,
they could not recognize the
impossible and quixotic
character of their
self-appointed task."
Whether it's Bentham trying to
derive maxims of conduct from
the postulative pleasure-seeking
and pain-avoidance,
or Rousseau trying to come up
with a system of government
taking men as they are and their
laws as they might be,
or Kant trying to see what
principles human beings as they
currently are would affirm from
every conceivable standpoint,
it's never going to work.
The morality that comes out of
this kind of reasoning is going
to seem, and actually will be,
unsatisfying to us.
And so if you now go back and
look at some of the puzzles and
conundrums we came up with when
we were considering those
different theories,
MacIntyre would say,
"Well, you shouldn't be
surprised.
You shouldn't be surprised that
objective utilitarianism allows
people to take advantage of one
another in appalling ways,
and you shouldn't be surprised
that subject of utilitarianism
allows people to ignore one
another in a morally appalling
way.
Because what makes things seem
morally appalling to you,
treat people with dignity,
don't lie,
cheat and steal,
these are maxims that we know
people have a tendency to
disobey,
and so that's the point of them.
They're to make us behave
better, and you're not going to
be able to derive them in this
sense from a completely
empirically accurate description
of human beings as we find them
in the world."
So it's a kind of secular
doctrine of the fall.
In Christian thinking we have
the fall,
and then we have inadequate
human beings,
and the possibility of
redemption through internalizing
and accepting Christ as your
savior.
This is a secular version of
the fall;
the secular version of fallen
man, untutored,
ill-formed human nature,
and then we have what we could
be if we are properly formed,
and then the system of the
rules of ethics that are going
to get us from the one to the
other.
And it's the virtues within
practices that achieving them,
or achieving lives lived in
accordance with them that enable
us to realize our purposes in a
good way,
and it's the rules and norms
governing those practices that
get us from A to B.
And the big problem with the
Enlightenment philosophically is
what I've just said to you,
that they try and engage in
this quixotic task,
but in politics itself it's the
creation of an emotivist world.
It's a creation of a world that
separates means from ends;
that values instrumental
reasoning, the business school
world at large.
The world in which we make
ourselves agnostic about
people's purposes and just try
to set ourselves up as a most
efficient executor of any
purpose.
"Have skills,
will travel."
"I'm a consultant."
"For what?"
"Well, whatever you
need."
That's what he finds
politically shocking and
appalling, but he thinks it's
underpinned by this whole
philosophical scheme.
Now, MacIntyre wrote this
during the--this book came out
in 1984, which was at the height
of the Cold War.
One of the points he was making
was everybody thinks that the
great battle of our time is the
confrontation between capitalism
and communism,
but for MacIntyre these are two
sides of the same coin because
they are both ways in which this
Enlightenment project has been
played out in politics and
they're both,
for him, appalling.
I started out saying to you
MacIntyre thought of himself as
a person on the political left,
at least when he was young when
he wrote Marxism and
Christianity and Against
the Self-Images of the Age
and those early books,
but it's in a different sense.
It's not like Robert Bork said
at one point in his confirmation
hearings,
you all are really too young to
remember this,
but they questioned him about
his changing ideological beliefs
and at one point he said,
"Well, I've always thought
if you're not a socialist before
the age of 30 you have no heart,
and if you are a socialist
after the age of 30 you have no
head."
This isn't MacIntyre.
He wants to say the whole
Enlightenment venture,
whether it's in its capitalist
or its socialist form is a
variant of this deeply muddled,
hopeless quest to develop a
science of politics based on
human nature as we find it.
And so his prescriptions are
rather different.
He says, "What matters at
this stage is the construction
of local forms of community
within which civility and the
intellectual and moral life can
be sustained through the new
dark ages which are already upon
us."
He's not a utopian;
he's a dystopian,
almost.
"And if the tradition of
the virtues was able to survive
the horrors of the last dark
ages,
we are not entirely without
grounds for hope.
This time however,
the barbarians are not waiting
beyond the frontiers;
they have already been
governing us for quite some
time.
And it is our lack of
consciousness of this that
constitutes part of our
predicament.
We are waiting not for Godot,
but for another--doubtless very
different--St.
Benedict."
Now people criticized MacIntyre
for a variety of things,
but one of the things they
criticized him for was that this
seems to be sort of throwing up
your hands and saying,
"The whole world is
terrible.
We're about to enter the new
dark ages, and there's not much
we can do about it except hunker
down and hope."
And he wrote several books,
probably the most important of
which is a book called,
Whose Justice?
Which Rationality? in an
attempt to respond to these
criticisms.
I'll talk about some of that in
a minute.
On the actual politics that
flow from this,
he never had anything more to
say than this,
so it is a diagnosis without a
cure.
I said this was written at the
height of the Cold War.
If you look at the post-Cold
War and you say,
"What would MacIntyre say
today?"
it's not at all clear because
he certainly would not be a fan
of militant Islam,
but it's not clear what he
would, you know,
he would probably find the
spread of globalization as just
one more step in this appalling
triumph of instrumental
reasoning and values.
So I think he would be no less
despondent,
and I think his diagnosis--this
is pure speculation,
I haven't had this conversation
with him--
but my guess is that his
diagnosis of militant Islam and
Jihadism and all of that would
be,
he would just say, "Well,
it's an inevitable undertow.
It's an inevitable reaction by
the losers from globalization
against the endless spread of
Enlightenment ideas."
I think in some ways there
could be a more interesting
MacIntyrian analysis of China in
that,
in China, we see now the fusion
of communist politics and
capitalist economics neither of
which shows any signs of going
anywhere.
And so when in 1984 somebody
had said,
"Well, capitalism and
communism are two sides of the
same coin,"
people would have been quite
dismissive.
When you think about China
today, it's quite thought
provoking.
So that's MacIntyre in a
nutshell.
Lots of it's quite appealing.
This account of human beings,
how many people--
never mind the unrealism of the
politics,
how many find this account of
human nature plausible,
true to your own experience?
At least some. Not that many?
We do, you know we want--we've
sort of got lots of unrequited
love.
We want to be liked.
We want to be wanted,
and we want to be wanted by
cool people, or people we think
are cool.
So that whole side of it seems
right, and the notion that
political morality should
somehow be an improving thing
seems right.
That you can't just derive it
from the--
as Rousseau said it,
"If you take all of our
individual preferences,
and add them up,
and get rid of the pluses and
minuses that cancel one another
out," that's maybe the
general will,
but MacIntyre would say,
"It's going to be the
lowest common denominator.
It's going to cater to our base
instincts and we are malleable,
shapeable, improvable creatures
and we're not happy unless
that's actually happening."
So all of that seems right,
but on the other hand,
as I mentioned to you,
MacIntyre makes one huge
concession to the way of
thinking that at least motivated
the Enlightenment,
which was that Aristotle was
wrong to say we don't reason
about ends.
Aristotle took ends as given
and said we only reason about
means.
So the big challenge for
MacIntyre is to say,
"Well, how do you say ends
can be put in question as
subjects for debate,
but not then wind up with
emotivism?"
How do you structure?
How do you put limits,
if you like,
on debates about ends which
recognizes that people do,
in fact, you know--a difference
between human beings and dogs,
let say, or lions is that dogs
and lions can't think critically
about their own ends.
They just think instrumentally
about how--their ends really are
given.
Dog wants to sit on a warm
couch.
A lion wants to kill a buck,
and there's no question about
that for a dog or a lion.
How you get on a warm couch
without being kicked off it by
some nasty human,
that's a question for a dog,
but not whether you want to be
on it.
Human beings aren't like that.
Human beings are capable of
thinking critically about
purposes and goals.
What MacIntyre wants to say is
we have the structure of an
Aristotelian psyche but not the
content.
We are not, in the end,
dogs and lions in that sense.
We can critically appraise our
goals,
but then we can argue about
them, and then we can disagree
about them,
and we can even have civil wars
about them when it really gets
down to it.
So what do you do with the fact
that we reason about goals?
That's why he introduces the
concept of a practice.
He says, "Well,
it's true we reason about
goals, but we don't pluck them
from nowhere.
We're born into practices where
the goals are defined,
where the goal of chess is to
get the person checkmate with as
many of their pieces on the
board as possible.
You don't say,
"Let's invent a board
game."
You say, "What are the
goals of chess?"
And so they're given by
practices or communities,
and if we think about what is a
practice or a community over
time, it's a tradition.
And so what he wants to say is
we're born into practices and
communities and we reproduce
them into the future simply by
living in them.
We inherit, we live,
and we reproduce into the
future,
so it's a little reminiscent,
or perhaps even more than a
little reminiscent of Burke's
line about,
yes, we are part of a social
contract,
but it's a contract among those
who are dead,
those who are living,
and those who are yet to be
born.
And so, yes, we do question.
You might play chess for a time
and say,
"Well, should it really be
the goal of chess to beat the
person with as many of their
pieces on the board as possible?
Why?
Maybe getting their subordinate
pieces on the way to before the
checkmate should be a goal of
chess."
You could have a debate.
Does it take more skill to
knock off the knights,
and the bishops and so on in
order and then get the
checkmate,
or does it take more skill to
get the person checkmate with
their knights and bishops on the
board.
And that could be a debate you
could have, but it's a contained
debate.
It's a structured debate.
And he wants to say our debates
about ends are always like that.
Think about debates,
getting closer to home for
MacIntyre, think about debates
within with Catholic Church.
The next generation of
Catholics doesn't say,
"Should we have a church?
Should it be organized?
Should the bishop of Rome have
a special status?
Should there be papal
infallibility?"
No, you're born into a
structure that's already there,
and then maybe you say,
"Well, why is there papal
infallibility?
It's only a relatively recent
creation.
It doesn't make sense."
So your questioning of ends is
always from the vantage point of
somebody who's born into an
inherited tradition.
And it doesn't make sense to
criticize it from the
perspective of outer space.
It doesn't make sense to any of
the participants,
and it won't ultimately give
you any answers that'll be in
any sense meaningful to you.
And so he sees traditions as
the mechanisms through which
practices are reproduced over
time,
and he wants to say,
yes, there is argument about
ends within traditions,
but it's always this kind of
structured argument that is
shaped by the way in which
questions come up within
traditions.
He says somewhere,
"Of course,
part of what it means to be a
Jew is to argue about what it
means to be a Jew,
that within the Jewish
tradition that is one of the
things that people argue about
and disagree about,
but it's always going to be
this bounded,
structured disagreement that
brings to bear other ideas
within the tradition on some
particular traditional claim.
For those of you who like
philosophical jargon Michael
Walzer wrote a book along
comparable lines where he talked
about the idea that the only
effective criticism is imminent
criticism which is a bit like--
imminent for Walzer,
is a bit like internal for
MacIntyre.
If you want to influence
Catholics to change their
behavior you're not going to
influence them unless you appeal
to values they embrace,
to norms they embrace,
to elements of the tradition
they accept and show them how
they are undermined by the
particular thing that you are
criticizing.
So internal criticism,
imminent criticism,
not ex cathedra criticism made
from outside a whole system of
norms, and values,
practices, institutions.
You might think you're right,
but it'll never have an effect
on the people you're trying to
influence.
So MacIntyre's very much in
that spirit.
We can argue and reason about
ends, but only from inside
traditions and practices.
Okay, we're out of time,
and I will finish up with this
and then start talking about
democracy on Monday.